failed former president Donald Trump
once arrested twice impeached has been
indicted a second time this time
federally he will be arrested and booked
on Tuesday in Miami at 3 P.M Eastern
Time ladies and gentlemen it is
happening and it is even more
unprecedented if you can if you can even
say such a such a thing
um wow what a day what a night CNBC
report
ex-president's arraignment comes day
before his birthday Donald Trump has
become the first U.S president former or
otherwise to be indicted on federal
criminal charges Trump announced in
Thursday night posts on his truth social
platform that prosecutors notified his
attorneys he had been indicted NBC News
confirmed soon after that
he faces seven charges including making
false statements conspiracy to obstruct
according to Trump's own lawyer James
trustee
the charges also include willfully
retaining documents in violation of the
Espionage Act
Trump the leading Contender for the GOP
Presidential nomination is scheduled to
appear Tuesday at a federal courthouse
in Miami the former president had kept
reams of classified documents and boxes
at his Mar-A-Lago Resort in South
Florida until federal agents raided it
last year and seized the records Trump
says he's innocent and ripped the case
as a hoax it is very important to
understand a number of distinctions
between this and what is happening with
the indictment and arrest in New York
the New York arrest is on state charges
this is a Federal indictment this is not
necessarily the only Federal indictment
that Donald Trump is facing because this
is only related to the documents there
is also a federal investigation
going on into Donald Trump's role in
inciting the Trump Riots of January 6
2021 no charging decision has been made
there and at minimum there are
additional State charges possible
against Donald Trump in the state of
Georgia we will learn more about that
sometime between I believe the dates are
July 11 and September 1st or July 1st
and September 11th something along those
lines none of this none of this is at
this time evidently politically
motivated
a Witch Hunt
a perversion of the justice system or
anything like that we're going to delve
into those aspects in details but Trump
indicted federally historic days in the
United States let's now go to Donald
Trump's reaction Donald Trump started
posting uncontrollably to truth social
after we learned last night that he has
been indicted federally and will have to
appear in Miami on Tuesday first and
foremost if you just sort of like scroll
through
Trump's truth social
every few minutes there's a post it's
either a meme or a video or people
praying with Trump or Republicans
supporting Trump and you can scroll
scroll scroll like we're just scrolling
here endlessly and there is just no
shortage of this stuff truth social
apparently having some glitches but
Trump's spending hours and hours and
hours posting this stuff one of the
first things he did last night upon the
indictment was post a video which we
will look at in a moment but just before
that he posted a three truth rant which
reads as follows the corrupt Biden
Administration has informed my attorneys
that I have been indicted
with a capital i
seemingly over the boxes hoax even
though Joe Biden has 1850 boxes at the
University of Delaware additional boxes
in Chinatown DC with even more boxes at
the University of Pennsylvania
and documents strewn all over his garage
floor where he Parks his Corvette which
is secured by only a garage door that is
paper thin and open much of the time
this is a former president ladies and
gentlemen page two I have been summoned
to appear at the federal courthouse in
Miami on Tuesday at 3 P.M I never
thought it possible that such a thing
could happen to a former president of
the United States who received far more
votes than any sitting president in the
capital H history of our Capital C
country and is currently leading by far
all capital c candidates both Democrat
and Republican in capital P polls of the
2024 presidential election I am an
innocent man and lastly on page three
this is indeed a dark day for the United
States of America we are a country in
serious and Rapid decline but together
we will make America great again now
we're going to look at the video
but the most important point about all
of this that I can make to you
and that is important not to lose sight
of as we are going to see the fire hose
of propaganda really get ramped up over
the next few weeks and days and months
there are those on the right who want
you to believe
that because Donald Trump is being
indicted the system is broken they point
to the Trump indictment and say see this
is the problem with the country are
institutions aren't trustworthy we are a
nation in Decline this is all bad
and they couldn't be more wrong the
indictments of trump prove that at least
at this point in the process no one is
above the law they love to say if they
can do it to Trump they could do it to
anybody we knew that they could do it to
anybody and we know that when we say
there's a two-tier justice system we
talk about the wealthy and Elite with
access to the best lawyers and unlimited
money for defenses and everybody else we
knew about the two-tier justice system
they want to tell you the two to your
justice system is left Wingers and
right-wingers there is no evidence of
that
and what we have to accept
if we honestly assess the situation is
that Trump's indictments tell us no one
is above the law that's a good thing now
whether he will get special treatment in
later phases of this remains to be seen
here's Trump's video that he put out
it's very stupid
very sadly We're a nation of decline
and yet they go after a popular
president a president that got more
votes than any sitting president in the
history of our country irrelevant to
whether one committed a crime of course
by far
ended much better the second time in the
election than
the first irrelevant and they go after
him on a Box's hugs just like the
russia-russia Russia hoax and all of the
others this has been going on for seven
years they can't stop because it's
election interference at the highest
level there's never been anything like
what's happened I'm an innocent man I'm
an innocent person they had the Mueller
hoax the Mueller report and that came
out no collusion after two and a half
years well I'm convinced that was set up
by Hillary Clinton and Democrats but
this is what they do this is what they
do so well if they would devote their
energies to honesty and integrity would
be a lot better for our country so it's
basically the typical grievances from
Trump after a three trust trust after a
three truth screed on Truth Central so
Trump losing it but this is nothing
compared to Fox News host Mark Levin I
did a stream last night as news breached
the wires of Donald Trump's Federal
indictment and one of the individuals
who we watched live have a complete and
total mental breakdown on live
television was this Fox News host Mark
Levin who some consider to be a great
legal analyst I have not seen a meltdown
like this in years on media of any kind
you've got to see this here is Mark
Levin essentially saying this is
nonsense Trump is innocent they're going
after him for politics this guy should
maybe try decaf and list meetings
endless meetings with with bidens with
Hunter Biden's business partners Bob
olinsky who ties Joe Biden to the crimes
Mr Big Mr 10 and what is Biden say well
then where's the money he's asking us
come and Catch Me If You Can the idea
that this man is isn't under a criminal
investigation and that they criminalize
the damn document case to go after
Donald Trump is sickening and I would
say this to our fellow Americans This
was by the way during the Hannity
program Hannity just standing by during
this entire thing don't be Bamboozled by
these cable channels and these fools who
come on and tell you like this guy well
he's not above the law are you kidding
me Democrat attorney general in New York
Democrat prosecutor in Manhattan
Democrat prosecutor in Atlanta Democrat
attorney general in Washington D.C what
do you you mean he's not above the law
there is no law what's going on here is
a disgusting disgrace it is war on Trump
isn't this the best it is war on the
Republican party and it is a war on a
republic the radical left is doing what
the radical left does while they cover
up for Biden the way they cover it up
for Hillary cover up what bring evidence
of crimes they seem Furious that other
presidents or presidential candidates
aren't also getting indicted just
because it looks like Trump committed
crimes here is that this went on the
reviewers who were tuning out and then
tuning back into the stream and Levin
was still going tell you something
have crossed the Rubicon twice which has
never been done and we will never
forgive you never ever and that's the
bottom line I'm done all right and so he
was done but we'll go back and look at
just a couple other moments just a
really tough night for Mark Levin
they're throwing all these process
crimes and all these crimes that grow
out of the criminal investigation
against Trump what did he do with the
documents did he sell him to the Enemy
No that's why we have an Espionage Act
not the trick of a president what did he
do did he burn them all no the
government has all the documents back so
there is no violation of the
presidential records act at this point
but they throw the book at him they go
after his attorneys they make them
testify they're attorneys under the
crime fraud exemption to attorney-client
privilege that means he didn't have due
process as our lawyers were being
subjected to interrogations and they had
hundreds of in a person all right I
think you get it and then putting a
final point on it Mark Levin talking
about Trump's age
president Trump was 76 years old
if the Department of Justice gets his
way he will die in federal prison now of
course I don't believe that that's going
to happen I don't believe Trump is going
to do a single day of prison time I've
said it before I continue to believe
that if I'm wrong I will eat my
microphone but I don't think Trump's
going to be doing any prison time at all
an incredible 24 hours in America we are
going to be covering Trump's uh
arraignment as as it will will be on
Tuesday at 3 P.M Live on YouTube twitch
and Facebook it is happening ladies and
gentlemen a now twice indicted and soon
to be twice arrested Donald Trump will
find himself in federal custody before
he knows it Tuesday in a federal
courthouse I hope you will join us for
it this is accountability at least the
possibility of accountability for many
alleged misdeeds and that is a good
thing we're going to take a break what a
program we have for you today
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show of course
continues to depend on viewers and
listeners like you to support the work
that we do we aren't the daily wire we
don't have the rich Millionaires and
maybe even billionaires we just depend
on folks like you and you can become one
of our supporters by signing up at
joinpakman.com let's go to the audience
via Discord
davidpackman.com Discord and hear what
is on the minds of the people the minds
of the people we will go first I hope
I'm pronouncing this correctly to Tressa
of Minnesota is that correct Tressa
well I pronounce it Teresa can you hear
me Teresa welcome yes
great
listen I'm from Minnesota as you know we
are a blue state I'm a Democrat I'm
Progressive I'm liberal
I like to say that I will vote for Joe
Biden even if he is slumped over in a
wheelchair drooling because the GOP is
that dangerous um
foreign
we know that the GOP big part of their
platform
so far has been big heavy anti-trans
transgender you know they don't even
want them to exist and they pull in a
lot of suburban women when they hear
about children you know
children are being mutilated blah blah
blah which is not even true but you know
the response from the left seems to be
um dismissive oh they make up a such a
small minority of you know Democrat
percentage of the demographic of the
population it's not even worth talking
about
and I kind of disagree and I have two
points
um that I would like to talk about
number one
I don't know what it's like in other
states but like I said I live in
Minnesota liberal state
and
corporations and companies and
um you know board meetings and park
boards and City Council meetings and
knitting groups
all start off their meetings by asking
people what their names are and to
declare your preferred pronoun I mean
this is there's not even a transgender
person in the room there might not be a
transgender person in a 10-mile radius
and it seems overboard just like the GOP
goes overboard I think sometimes the
left goes overboard I think the
intentions are good you know they want
to be inclusive and accepting but asking
someone what their pronouns are is kind
of intrusive I think so let me address
this Theresa because you've said a lot
and I don't want to forget all the
different points you made so first of
all from a very tactical level my
opinion is I'm also against the
unprovoked
putting forward of pronouns as a matter
of core of of sort of standard operating
procedure I know a number of teachers
who teach in schools where they started
the year doing that and then they very
quickly figured out hey you know what
this actually isn't great number one
it's not great because the truth is
trans people are a very small part of
the population and so the why is it that
we are doing this absent any particular
reason to do it now one reason would be
well you're making everyone in the room
comfortable because by by having
everyone State their pronouns someone
who has pronouns that might not be
obvious from their physical appearance
will be more comfortable the
Counterpoint to that Teresa is there
might be people in the group in the
audience in the room whatever who are
currently struggling with gender
identity who actually don't want to be
in the position to have to State here
are my pronouns so I would call it like
it it Nets out to zero but my general
view is I don't think that that's
something we need to be doing I'm very
comfortable as a trans empathetic and
supportive individual
basically taking my best guess at what
people's pronouns are which by the way
when you're talking to the person rarely
even comes up it's usually when
referring to the person to some other
person but anyway and if I get it wrong
it's very obvious that I'm not doing it
in bad faith and someone can correct me
and whatever so that's my view on the
statement of pronouns piece does that
make sense to you
yes yes triple yes okay yes to all of
that yes to all of that on the earlier
thing you said Teresa which was along
the lines of
there may be it may not be the best
approach to just say this isn't even a
big enough issue to talk about and
dismissing it outright you're you're not
big on that I think I understood is that
right
correct my thought on this is sort of as
follows
we should recognize that
it is no longer acceptable
to treat or
um stereotype
that many groups that at one point was
okay to do like there was a point in the
United States where it was just totally
acceptable to use the n-word when
referring to black black people separate
sinks bathrooms water fountains and
restaurants okay that's changed it's no
longer acceptable to do that there was a
point at which using the f word for gay
people was acceptable and you could
openly discriminate that's not
acceptable so what what's happening is
that
Ace the the right is
going to smaller and smaller groups in
order to find someone that maybe they
can get away with scapegoating and I do
think it's important to recognize that
we shouldn't overstate the prevalence of
trans people because like this happens
with anti-semites Theresa if you ask
some anti-semites listen what percentage
of the population do you think is even
Jewish and sometimes they'll say five
ten twenty percent and then you go you
know it's point two percent right so I
do think it's good
to be accurate about the size of a
population
at the same time I agree with you that
just saying it's not an issue because it
isn't a big population it's not a very
that's not a super strong defense I
agree with you
yeah I don't think that it's a small
issue because when people are being
harmed it's an issue right you know
um companies whatever can have their uh
diversity and inclusion policies I don't
know most companies have a hand book or
whatever make it very clear that there
are consequences then ramifications for
p treating people disrespectfully by not
calling them by the name that they wish
to be called by whether you think that
name belongs to what they look like or
not sure you know yeah so it's not
ignoring it but not going overboard the
other way which I think alienates a lot
of people Theresa and I I mostly agree
with everything you're saying I know you
had more but I have so many people
waiting and we've been on almost 10
minutes I want to keep getting people on
if that's okay okay okay thank you all
right Teresa from Minnesota very
powerful stuff let's go next to oh boy I
have no idea how to say this name I
believe it's a Scottish name it looks
like it would be is it I'm going to just
take a wild guess at how it's pronounced
even though there's so many is it
pronounced Rory
you are very close it is a brewery Rory
well listen Rory from Scotland welcome
to the program
hi there
what's on your mind I was just uh I was
just thinking just because you know I
have sort of like an outside view of the
us obviously being from across the pond
I was just wondering what your opinion
was on the sort of like Global
right-wing populist movement whether you
think it was as strong as it was back in
2000 during the 2010s when you know
brexit happened and Trump got elected
and all that or do you think now it's in
more of a retreat and you see some of
these extreme policies come from the
Republicans and the conservatives over
here as their last kind of like flailing
of a sort of like ideology that's kind
of failing at the moment I don't have
anything empirical to tell you globally
about whether the right-wing populist
movement is in Retreat or not my feeling
okay so I'm just going by feeling and I
know facts don't care about feelings but
I have no facts so I'm going to give you
my feelings right my feeling is that
because of the losses that the Maga
right-wing populist movement has
suffered now multiple elections in a row
in the United States and the degree to
which Auntie woke doesn't seem to be
winning and they're suffering legal
defeats and moral defeats my feeling is
that it is at least starting a retreat
at this time
yeah
and I don't know what gets us in terms
of like the 2024 election necessarily
yeah for sure like I I kind of for in
the UK it's kind of the same because you
have the conservatives who have like
been trounced at local elections and
they're polling really badly nationally
but they're still like pushing the same
sort of like culture War policies that
have just kind of been imported from
America so like the whole trans rights
debates has flared up especially uh
where I'm from in Scotland
uh so I I think just looking over here I
think in some places like the US and the
UK is faltering quite a lot just just
because of not necessarily the ideology
in itself but the incompetent people
behind it it's both right I mean you can
you can take bad ideas and popularize
them with competent demagogues you can
take uh good ideas and see them lose
miserably because the messengers aren't
good you could both can have yeah
exactly yeah
all right that's all I want to ask yeah
thank you very much I appreciate it
great to hear from you excellent always
uh welcoming our Scottish callers let's
go to Gene from Long Island Gene welcome
to the David packman show what is on
your mind today
hello hi you're on the air
awesome
um my dad has raised me as a progressive
and the most thing uh the thing I've
cared most about while growing up is
Reproductive Rights okay and so we've
been blaming the GOP and Trump taking
credit for overturning Roe but looking
back I'm thinking the Democrats should
have made sure this right remained in
place they knew the GOP was planning and
plotting for all these years and my
other uh I wanted to get your thoughts
on that and also how how I can help in
this fight to get it to get those
Reproductive Rights back I've donated to
Planned Parenthood but uh you know if
there if you had any insight on Insight
on that as well so the first criticism
is a fair one which is couldn't
Democrats when they did control the
House and Senate and presidency have
codified Roe v Wade such that it would
no longer be up to the Supreme Court to
do away with it is that more or less the
critique in yes absolutely I think it's
completely Fair my question is if Obama
couldn't even get background checks done
with the House and Senate after the
Sandy Hook shooting could they really
have codified Roe v Wade I don't know
the answer I don't know the answer but I
think as a criticism it's completely
Fair
yeah so there's a practical question
it's something that actually upsets me
a lot because this is something I've
cared about for a long time so you know
looking into the future hopefully at
some point
we can get that back and I just don't
know how that would be now in terms of
your other question what is the best use
of your time money resources whatever in
order to essentially what you're saying
is keep abortion legal and maintain
access to it for people who want to
access it without being done away with
with Roe v Wade being done away with
right now this is a state issue so
in the states that have passed
restrictive laws You could argue it
makes sense to focus there so I don't
know exactly whether it should be focus
on getting candidates at the state level
in these states that have essentially
banned abortion to get elected so maybe
they can overturn it or is it donating
to Planned Parenthood of Florida or
Texas or whatever I don't pretend to
know exactly I probably it's an all of
the above approach but I think that for
as long as it remains a state issue
which it is right now the focus for
activists should be on the states in
which it is most in peril
awesome thank you I really appreciate it
all right Gene from Long Island great to
hear from you uh very strong questions
today I must say let's go next to
Richard from Slidell or is it pronounced
Slidel probably Slidell right it must be
Richard please unmute unmute yourself
sir
no boy
Richard you have self-muted and if you
unmute I would be able to hear you
all right and Richard refusing
to take off that mute let's go to Miguel
from Central Florida
Miguel from Central Florida Welcome to
the David Pacman show what can I do for
you today
hi David how does my mic sound it sounds
beautiful
oh perfect uh I wanted to ask uh being
someone that's coming from Central
Florida I've obviously seen kind of the
rise of the the santis and a lot of the
rise of the right wing culture War
issues yep so I was wondering
uh considering DeSantis expanded his
lead in
Florida this time around to what extent
would you place the blame on the local
Florida Democratic party or you could
even translate it to the national issue
as well how much would you kind of
assign the blame to the Democratic party
for not being able to effectively
counter the kind of right wing uh
messaging that has dominated the media
almost since Trump has won the election
there's a couple different things here
part of this is timing and what I mean
by that is I think that if the DeSantis
re-election if in Florida
were November 2023 rather than November
2022 I don't think DeSantis wins by 19.
now he probably still wins but the
reason I say he doesn't win by 19 is
since November the tide really has
turned on a lot of this culture War
stuff that DeSantis ran his campaign on
so I think part of part of it was timing
and timing was the reason DeSantis
expanded uh his his margin of Victory
now can we blame Democrats to some
degree sure you almost always can right
like you can almost always do something
to lose by less even if you're going to
lose than if you do nothing at all I
don't know enough about the internal
dynamics of the Florida what's going on
in Florida to be able to specifically
lay blame but I think big picture big
picture there was like a peak in the
culture War stuff right around November
2022 which did help some Republicans
like the santis and had those elections
been held six months later like now I
think the results would have been at
least slightly different
yeah no I could definitely see that
unfortunately I'd say that the the
ground game for the Florida Democratic
party is I'd say almost non-existent
here is that right definitely see how uh
no it was uh I mean back during the
election I would have people knocking on
my door handing out the Santos pamphlets
and I live in a blue County you know and
I I didn't get a single Democratic
person knock on my door although I will
say that it was mostly the unions that
were out here uh trying to campaign for
candidates interesting but I guess that
would be a conversation for another day
if anything but yeah
thank you so much there is Miguel from
Central Florida we're going to take the
quickest of breaks and then we're gonna
come right back here and hear from more
of you okay so if you're holding on to
talk to me just hold on a little bit
longer
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's go back to the Discord lines and
hear from some more people in the
audience davidpackman.com
Discord of course is the only place the
only place to call into the show
important to understand their accept no
substitution I think is the point that
I'm trying to make let's go to Josh from
Michigan Josh from Michigan welcome to
the program what's on your mind
hi David cool uh it's nice to uh touch
base here
um I was just thinking about I I look at
uh the
270towin.com uh app and and I look at
the map and I see all you really need to
have a stable Democratic president going
into the future our existing blue States
plus Wisconsin Michigan and Pennsylvania
and the existing problem these three
states have are sort of loss of
population or stagnating population and
my question is kind of what do you think
these three states can do to sort of
gain population and and
stay strong for a more Progressive
future because that's that's kind of
where I'm coming from well let me
propose something different to you Josh
you're not wrong that one way if you
hold voter turnout level one way for
Democrats to do better in those States
would be to get people to move to those
States who would vote for Democrats
certainly that's possible I think that
there's an easier way though it's much
easier to get an existing Wisconsin
resident who doesn't care enough to vote
to go and vote than it is to get someone
from like Connecticut to move to
Wisconsin do you understand the point
I'm making
yeah that makes a lot of sense in other
words you have the voters both parties
have the voters to win because voter
turnout is so pathetically low in the
United States I think it's far easier to
convince existing wisconsinites and
michiganders or whatever the right term
is
um to just go and vote rather than to
try to get people to move there and the
truth is getting people to move
somewhere depends on so many things
really beyond our conversational control
you can convince people to vote just
through a conversation about why it's
important and it doesn't require them to
sell and buy a new house find a job rent
a U-Haul or any of those things so I
think the focus should be not on getting
people to move to these key States but
just activating uh voters I will say one
other thing just because you brought
this up one of the real questions about
2024 is okay so whether it's Trump Biden
or Biden DeSantis or whatever
if we start with the 2020 map
we then have to say what is the path for
Republicans to win and when you start
looking it's not a great path for
Republicans now I'm not saying Biden's
got this I'm not saying that by any
means but you look at some of these
states Trump got Florida in 2020. so you
don't even have to worry like Biden won
and didn't get Florida imagine that
Georgia which Biden won went to the
Republican which it often does that
still leaves Democrats with 290
electoral votes imagine that Republicans
also get Arizona back which I think has
gone more blue Josh since 2020.
Democrats still have 279. so the the
point here is not that Republicans can't
win or whatever my point is if I think
about 2020 and think about what's
changed I think Georgia has stayed as
purple as it was I think Arizona has
gone more blue and so Republicans do
have some work to do to get to 270 votes
in 2024.
yeah I totally agree yeah they have a
lot of work to do
um and I I think Michigan for for what
it's worth has gone a little bit left
since 2020
um 2022 it went for Gretchen Whitmer by
11 yep uh and she's done some positive
things here
um a little bit slower on the clip than
Minnesota but
um just foundational stuff that I think
is going to be great for the future of
the state here
excellent stuff all right Josh thank you
so much for the call
you're welcome all right there goes Josh
from Michigan with I mean those are
important issues nitty-gritty
nitty-gritty stuff for sure let's stick
in Michigan for a little bit and go to
Trent from Ann Arbor uh Trent from Ann
Arbor welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
hi David can you hear me all right yes I
can
hey uh first want to say I've been
hoping to get in uh and talk to you for
a while now I've been watching for
almost a year uh love what you do really
great um definitely would love to see
more voices out there do what you do
thank you
um I wanted to talk about
I know you've been covering like the uh
other Republicans jumping in on the
primary and stuff
um and you've been talking about a lot
about like what they're doing makes no
sense right I fully agree it's like you
can't get
enough voters with Trump in the running
and I generally believe that most of
them are banking on Trump
dropping out for one reason or another
so I just wanted your thoughts on that
because that's the only way like the
only thing I can understand
them wanting you know doing the way
they're doing it the way they're doing I
don't think you're wrong Trent in the
sense that one idea about what's so so
there's a couple different ways that you
could try to win a Republican primary
you could try to win a Republican
primary by activating all the people
that already don't like Trump or you
could win a Republican primary by trying
to convince people who like Trump to
vote for you instead of trump or some
combination of these okay so these are a
couple different strategies if you're
trying to get the people who don't like
Trump to vote for you then you're gonna
have to criticize Trump and so far the
only guy who's really criticizing Trump
is Chris Christie DeSantis a little bit
but it's really Chris Christie who has
said I get it this nomination goes
through Trump so that's one approach the
other approach is okay if I sort of just
draw some distinctions with how I think
things should be done but don't really
insult Trump if Trump gets arrested
multiple more times and then it just
takes them off the campaign Trail and
whatever I can be here sort of like
Jerry in the episode where he's hanging
around the woman who just had a breakup
right he's like I'll just I'll be there
for her and then I'll just be there you
know the problem is DeSantis has 20
something so if DeSantis is already
doing that how is Tim Scott at two
percent gonna do the exact same thing
the math they can't all do it you know
so I don't I don't know what the
Dynamics of that primary will look like
in four to six weeks particularly now
with Christian who my guess is will get
at least attention for going after Trump
it'll be interesting to see what it
looks like in in a month or two
well and I guess I guess uh my last plan
is and to extend it further I just don't
understand
how people can be so dense like
you know I look and I see what they're
all saying and just general Republican
talking points and you know how how
dangerously we've treated uh you know
we've been on the edge of losing our
democracy yeah and I'm just sitting here
like how are you all complacent with
this you know like why why are we why is
there not more outrage and more vocal
outrage why can't at a certain point we
just say stop you can't do this you
can't lie and bring down our democracy
to suit your own needs I don't totally
get it I don't totally get it and it's
it's part of the I mean complacency or
even support for that I mean there's
still people who say Trump won there's
still people who defend the rioters from
January 6. it that's a much bigger
conversation Trent but bottom line it's
a mess it's a mess
that I fully agree yeah
all right well sorry to end on such a
disappointing note but I do appreciate
it thank you David all right there is
traps from Ann Arbor listen let's get
out of Michigan now because we've we've
been going to so many no offense to
Michigan but we've got to go to some
other state I feel like uh what about
Alexander from Ohio Alexander from Ohio
what's going on with you
David sir can you hear me I can hear you
fine
uh I was wondering with the millennial
and younger um population of America
leaning left
um do you think that we will in a couple
decades or so be kind of done with these
insane issues that we've been having to
deal with for the last couple years
what do you mean
well just kind of like
um the fact that everything is
like abortion gun laws these kinds of
all of these issues that
are the most important things in
politics today for us do you think with
the culture kind of leaning left in the
future
a lot of these issues will become just
more like we'll come to a conclusion
about them and then they'll become
non-issues I see what you're saying so
here's the thing
I do believe that many of the cultural
issues from today are not going to
remain cultural issues indefinitely
however
the right which depends on fear and
scapegoating to try to win is going to
move on to something else and then the
question is who then is further
victimized and
um that is a scary sort of proposition
so yeah I don't think the focus will be
what it currently is indefinitely but
then it's like who who will they go
after next and I don't I don't know
they're going to find someone to go
after and to base their culture War
around
so this does all just go on essentially
forever then I don't know about forever
and I don't know about it goes on goes
on like this but I think the point I'm
making is for the foreseeable future if
it's not trans people who are the target
it's going to be someone it's going to
be and and so we just have to be ready
for that
that makes a lot of sense David I was
also wondering what you think of Ohio if
you've ever been here yeah I've been to
uh let's see I've been to Cleveland and
at Cleveland I wasn't huge on it's it
was very pyongyang-like a lot of
concrete brutalist architecture where I
was but I might have only been in one
neighborhood and then I've been to
Columbus which was kind of cool Columbus
had a good this was a long time ago but
it had done a pretty good food scene and
uh yeah I don't have any particularly
um hot takes on uh on Ohio
well that's good because a lot of people
uh often uh you know make jokes about
Ohio but I'm fine with Ohio existing
let's put it that way
well I appreciate you follow David all
right thank you for answering questions
I really appreciate what you do thank
you Alexander from Ohio great to hear
from you let's go to Molly from Utah
next Molly please welcome to the program
what is on your mind today hi I um
I am very far left uh so I'm like a
socialist I don't know I guess I'm a
Libertarian social you're almost
Whispering try to speak up just a little
bit hold on yeah let me adjust the
microphone yeah can you hear me yes I
can
yeah so um I wanted to like bestow some
hopium to like people in general I'm a
Libertarian socialist so I work with the
DSA
and
it everybody always wonders like how do
you get party changes how do you like
get people to within a specific party
doesn't matter which one but how do you
get it to basically
um align with your beliefs okay and so
the the Tea Party used to do the whole
delegate thing for the Republican party
and that's how they shift a lot of local
leaders and so the DSA did
hello
okay the DSA
well we lost
Molly
uh all right
okay uh that was weird let's see if we
can uh squeeze somebody else in here
what about uh you're gonna have to be
sort of quick but how about Vance from
the Atlanta suburbs Vance welcome what's
on your mind
hi David can you hear me okay yes
okay so my question is how would the
2016 election season have gone if like
Hillary Clinton was a man like
everything else about her was the same
but she wasn't a woman she was just a
man like you know
it was so close it was so close
that if being a woman cost Hillary just
a few votes in some critical States You
could argue that would have been a
Difference Maker but here's the thing I
also want to add to that advance
there are so many single things that
could have been difference makers if
James Comey didn't do the second press
conference about Hillary Clinton if you
you know so you can play this game all
day long there are
a million different factors what was the
weather on Election Day or all these
different things
um I I think that it's an interesting
question to ask the answer is I'm sure
the outcome the the vote totals would
have differed somewhat from what they
were if Hillary Clinton were a man but I
don't know how useful as a general way
to analyze elections uh how useful it is
uh thanks for thanks for having me
that's all I have all right Vance from
the Atlanta suburbs and on that note we
will call it a day for live calls we
will take calls again and when we do I'm
telling you right now
I hope to hear from you we'll take a
quick break and be right back with much
more
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's check out what some of
you had to say about this week of shows
you can always email info
davidpackman.com but Facebook messages
YouTube comments tweets smoke signals
telegrams and snail mail May
occasionally be included the first
message today comes from Facebook I
could give you a hundred of these every
single Friday
but it is simply one you're an imbecile
of course the wrong your
to which our team knows you simply write
back with the correct your you
apostrophe re
and then we move on from there we
probably get uh eight to ten of these a
day and probably hundreds via YouTube
comment
uh obviously education a concern in the
United States we're not making fun of
people who lack access to a good
education
what I am pointing to is maybe don't
call other people stupid morons
imbeciles Etc
when you send a three-word message and
one of those three words is just the
wrong word okay so that's my advice it's
not about making fun of people please
let's just uh
let's keep it together folks okay the
bread table
comments about DeSantis and says he's
only a good candidate by comparison to
Trump uh speaking about Biden I mean I
think Dems are in serious trouble if
it's DeSantis versus Biden I don't like
DeSantis personally but I think he's a
very effective right-wing propagandist
and looks better to the average American
voter than two old guys keep in mind the
average voter doesn't have hard set
policy stances and votes largely on
outward appearance social image and
perception listen I don't know if you've
been watching the first two weeks of the
DeSantis president's president
presidential campaign
um
he's not an effective propagandist his
appearance and social image or a
disaster he couldn't be less charismatic
he couldn't be more awkward he's doing
the bobble head stuff he used the word
woke seven times in 28 seconds in a clip
that we looked at on Monday if that's a
guy who's relying on his outward
appearance to get elected I think he's
in trouble folks I really do Mr hipster
posted to the David packman show
subreddit ew David why would you go to
Florida for the beaches California is
leagues better Florida is trash
California beaches are infinitely better
and way more ecologically diverse couple
different things I want to mention here
number one
California overall has much more
beautiful beaches from the standpoint of
scenery I'm with you the downsides to
California beaches are that I like to go
in the water and I just don't have it in
me to go in the freezing water of the
Pacific and everybody anytime you say
this to people in California they say oh
no you go you go down to Manhattan Beach
and the waters warm it's warm and then I
step in there and my foot turns blue
I'm too old for this crap guys okay as a
kid I did it I want to be able to just
kind of walk right in this is why I
prefer like Aruba and Mexico but as far
as the United States goes the southern
tip just the very extra tip there of
Florida is a good spot and I have to say
in the summer it's hard to find nicer
beaches on the East Coast than Pensacola
although technically Pensacola was in
the Gulf I understand that but warm even
warmer than over in Miami so listen like
I'm with you about the beauty of it all
in California the whole thing but if I
want to go in the water it's just too
damn cold okay please please candy
hoarding commented Trump 2024 he pisses
off the establishment so that's the one
we need for the people
this is perfect as I've told you many
times before
there is a category of maggots or
magadonians as the new term may be
that doesn't care about policy
doesn't care about ideas doesn't care
about what's good for them or their
neighbors or whatever they care about
quote owning the libs
and so they think if Liberals are mad if
liberals don't like trump it must be
good for the people
it's an incredibly childish and pathetic
way to analyze what we should be doing
in terms of American politics with
elections and thinking about what sort
of policy would be good or bad but this
is what candy hoarding says
Trump because the establishment doesn't
like him most people don't like him I
hate to break it to you but yes but
forty percent of Republicans still like
them and that might be enough to win
Johnny X says it's ridiculous but at the
same time I don't want LGBT characters
in my kids media I know they exist but
that's not something kids should be
exposed to until they are teenagers
think about how stupid this is seriously
seriously you know now as a parent
I start to think about things like okay
when my daughter is three
inevitably she's going to look around
and see that there are kids who have a
mom and a dad and kids that have two
moms and kids that have two dads and so
she's going to be aware of the fact that
there are these different arrangements
and so in what way would it benefit her
or anybody for me to go out of my way to
make sure that this never comes up like
in school or in media she might see
something on a cartoon that mirrors
reality oh my goodness she shouldn't be
exposed to that and then you're telling
me when she's 13 now I go listen
some kids have two moms
that's a ridiculous way to raise a kid
so I don't really know what this
person's talking about this person may
not even actually have children because
it's very hard to imagine anyway in
which it would be damaging to be aware
of the fact that there are LGBT people
really really wacky stuff and we got a
lot of comments about this the guitar is
love wrote never really understood how
being gay goes against the family unit
you can be gay and still have a family
it happens all the time honestly I don't
think these people actually care about
conservative or Christian values I think
they're just homophobic I agree with
that
I agree with that the family unit is
damaged if there is someone who is gay
gay people are part of families and they
have families it's only damaging if
their family is homophobic and kicks
them out
uh Alberto Garcia is commenting about my
vaccination and says I doubt Pacman took
the Jab
but if he did
then I am looking forward to the day
that it works on him so Humanity does
not have to tolerate him anymore two
things number one Monday we went very
specifically about the risk of death
from vaccines and we looked specifically
at different vaccines we have data on
this stuff I encourage you if you care
about reality to check it out secondly I
doubt Pacman took the jab there are
people in the audience who think I'm
playing a character on the show
it happens all the time but where people
write in I've said a million times now
I've I've told you what my vaccination
situation is with the covet vaccine
and I've been vaccinated
why on Earth would I lie about that why
who what I don't who would I even be
serving what would be the point I'm not
playing a character on this show I just
tell you the things as they are
place
um RJ Carey about growing Christian
nationalism in the United States and
discussions about transgender identity
and so many different things RJ Carey
says it always cracks me up when people
who do believe that a virgin can give
birth to a supernatural figure lecture
others about biology and what is natural
LOL very much well said RJ very very
much well said
um I you know in general with the
biblical morality types I I would even
go further than this sometimes you know
they'll call me and they'll say David
you know without the Bible without this
without this structure
how do you know what's right and wrong
what's to stop you from just killing
people if you don't have some some
source that says it is wrong to kill or
it is wrong to murder there's a
distinction between kill and murder made
and some religious texts and when I hear
that I I think to myself wait a second
are you saying that were it not for this
supposed sacred text that communicates
to you what in most cases a Jewish
Carpenter in the sky wants you to do
were it not for that and the fear of
Eternal punishment as a result of what
that Jewish Carpenter in this guy wants
you to do or not do you'd be murdering
people like are you saying that without
that you'd be murdering people because
if that's what you're saying it doesn't
make a lot of sense to me I don't need
that to tell me that murder is wrong
anyway it's
I I we don't have to we don't have to
get into it
um here is someone Reminiscing on uh
when people would say the Pledge of
Allegiance I'm pronouncing it that way
for a particular reason Sylvia Potter
says I remember when Republicans would
pray and say the pledge pledge of
allegiant before they started their
meeting and we had a Bible study before
school started and we never had one
school shooting that was never heard of
families like mine would sit around the
dinner table and pray before a bite of
food was eaten we and a lot of other
families would get up every Sunday
morning and go to church watch old news
clippings back then and the news today
and tell me if you see any difference
and then tell me God doesn't exist you
are the one with the big problem I am
struggling to follow this but I guess
the argument is when the Pledge of
Allegiance or Allegiance was set in
school and there was Bible study in
school we didn't have school shootings
we also had way fewer guns that's the
first thing I would look at we had way
fewer guns circulating at that time uh
and Beyond before looking at the Pledge
of Allegiance I would consider the tool
that is being used for the shootings
before I look at a Bible I would
consider the tool that is being used for
these shootings but folks that this is
America
folks like that vote and for every
single one of them we need someone who's
going to think critically and rationally
about the issues facing the country and
vote as well to cancel that out
otherwise they will win and that's a
really really scary thing we have a
tremendous bonus show for you today sign
up at joinpakman.com you'll get instant
access and all of the other great member
benefits you're also doing a great thing
to support the work that we do I'll see
you on the bonus show if you're not a
member then sadly we will not be
reunited until Monday
foreign